We will generalize this
in subsequent lessons. We'll talk about so-called
projective measurements in lesson three, and then later on in the
third unit of the series,
we'll talk about general measurements, which are also called positive
operator valued measures or POVMs for short.
But for now, we'll restrict our attention to standard basis measurements.
When a measurement is
performed on a system, there will be some set
of possible outcomes of that measurement, which are classical outcomes,
and in the case of a
standard basis measurement, those possible outcomes are
precisely the classical states of whatever system is being measured.
Each of those classical states will be the outcome of the measurement with some probability, and that probability is
the absolute value squared
of the entry corresponding
to that classical state of whatever quantum state
vector the system was in immediately prior to being measured.
We know that the absolute value squared of any complex number is a non-negative real number, and we know from the definition
of quantum state vectors
that the sum of the absolute
value squared of the entries of a quantum state vector is equal to one.
So this makes sense. Each classical state will appear as the outcome of the
measurement with some probability and the probabilities sum to one.
Here are a few examples. First, suppose we have a
qubit in the plus state.
If we measure this qubit with respect to a standard
basis measurement, we get either a zero or
a one as the outcome.
The probability of getting a zero is the absolute value
squared of one over root two, which is 1/2, and that's the same
probability of getting a one.
So if you measure a plus state, you'll get a uniform random bit.
If the system is in a minus
state rather than a plus state, then measuring works in
exactly the same way.
The probabilities are, again, 1/2 for each possible outcome.
The only difference here is that the plus sign turned into a minus sign, but when we take the absolute
value, nothing changes.
If we measure this qubit state, the probability to get the outcome zero is the absolute value squared of one plus two times i
over three, which is 5/9,
and the probability to get the outcome one is the absolute value squared
of negative 2/3, which is 4/9.
And finally, measuring
the standard basis state, ket zero gives the outcome
zero with certainty, and likewise, measuring the state ket one
yields the outcome one with certainty. That's because the absolute
value squared of one is one.
Similar to what we had in
the probabilistic setting. We can associate these quantum
states, ket zero in ket one, with the system being in
those classical states,
and this example is consistent
with that interpretation.
Now, just like we had in
the probabilistic setting, if we measure a system when
it's in a quantum state,
then the state will change, in general, as a result of having
performed that measurement.
In particular, and again, this is exactly like we had
in the probabilistic setting.
If we measure a system and the outcome of the measurement
is the classical state a, then the new quantum state
of the system becomes ket a.
So for this state right
here, for instance, we see the same kind
of behavior that we had in the probabilistic setting.
If we measure then with probability 5/9, we obtain the outcome zero, in which case, the state
transitions to ket zero,
and with probability
4/9, the outcome is one, and the state transitions to ket one.
Sometimes this phenomenon is referred to as a collapse
of the quantum state, and it's the kind of
thing that keeps people
that study the foundations
of quantum mechanics awake at night.
But from a purely
mathematical perspective, it's really quite simple
and very much analogous to what we have in the probabilistic case.
The source of tension here, in some sense, concerns the fundamental
nature of quantum states and what they represent
and how they differ
from probabilistic states. But at a mathematical level, this is perhaps what you might expect.
Notice, by the way, that if
you measured a second time, then you would get exactly
the same result as you did for the first measurement.
So there's a limit on how
much classical information can be extracted from a quantum state, and we'll come back to this point soon
in another lesson. We've talked about quantum states as well as measurements, specifically standard basis measurements,
which provide a way to
extract classical information from quantum states.
The remaining topic for
this lesson is operations, specifically unitary operations, which describe how
quantum states of systems
can be changed. Naturally, given that quantum
state vectors are different from probability vectors, you would expect that set
of allowable operations
on quantum states is different than what we have for
classical information, and indeed, that's the case.
Whereas operations on probabilistic states are represented by stochastic matrices, operations on quantum state vectors
are represented by unitary matrices.
Here's the definition of unitary matrices.
A square matrix U having complex
number entries is unitary if it satisfies the equalities
that you see right here.